a piece of Las Vegas history crumbles to
the ground as an Infamous gentlemen's
club is demolished we're talking about
Crazy Horse 2 located on Industrial by
Sahara getting the boat from the city of
Las Vegas as the vacant building is a
hazard Victoria Saha joins us live with
what could be next for the property
Victoria
how much of the building is now in
in the very few businesses still in the
area they tell me this former
gentlemen's club has been an eyesore for
a very long time
a legendary Las Vegas club in pieces
but don't let the condition of this part
of Industrial Road fool you back in the
day when it was very busy yeah
it helped all the businesses around
owner of golden Beyond roizella is able
to see Crazy Horse Too from his store
and there was a lot of homeless people
problems the gentleman's club is no
stranger to headlines one of the former
owners Rick rosillo sold the property
after it was raided by the FBI in 2003.
he pleaded guilty to failing to pay
payroll taxes and was known for his mob
ties the federal government took over
the building before selling it but the
club closed its doors permanently in
2014 leaving it to stay vacant and rust
away what a waste of
property
if if they can do something for the
community or any other business it's
going to help all of us so it's a huge
waste of land that's what it is but this
past year multiple fires turning it into
a hazard the city of Las Vegas reports
asbestos was found on the property and
needed to be demolished by the owner
otherwise they were going to do it
themselves leaving many to wonder what
will come next
I did reach out to the property
management company to see what is next
for this Prime Property but I'm still
waiting to hear back Victoria Saha eight
news now thank Victoria according to the
city of Las Vegas once demolition has
completed the area will then be fenced
off